by putting together all of these pieces
you should be able to create a
presentation about your prototype for
any audience it's important to remember
though that you'll be making a lot of
these presentations if you want to
become an entrepreneur persistence will
be key moving forward both in improving
your prototype and improving your
presentation the important thing to
remember is that nobody gets everything
they need to run a business off of their
first demo and that every time you make
a prototype that gets poorer feedback
from users or a presentation that
doesn't wow your audience you're
learning more about the task and more
about how to move forward